die lage an der polnisch russischen
grenze eskaliert flüchtlinge gegen
soldaten eine humanitäre katastrophe auf
allen ebenen es gibt viele verletzte und
auch einen toten migranten bewaffnen
sich mit draht schneidern und steinen
versuchen mit aller gewalt nach polen in
die eu also zu kommen ihnen gegenüber
soldaten sie setzen blendgranaten und
wasserwerfer ein verteidigen die grenze
und ein polizist wird dabei schwer
verletzt schädelbruch aber der ansturm
ebbt nicht ab es tauchen immer mehr
menschen am grenzzaun auf verzweifelte
frauen und kinder bei temperaturen um
den gefrierpunkt die sehnsucht nach
einer besseren zukunft kostete ihn sein
leben der 19 jährige syrer ahmad al
hassan starb bei dem versuch nach europa
zu kommen der junge mann war in einem
fluss an der polnische bilder russischen
grenze er trunken 2300 kilometer
entfernt von seiner heimatstadt homs
wurde der flüchtling in dem kleinen
muslimischen dorfbewohner key dann am
montagabend beerdigt ein opfer der
perfiden flüchtlingspolitik von im
weißrussischen diktator lukaschenko den
neuesten zahlen der polnischen
grenzbehörde zufolge sitzen derzeit mehr
als 3500 menschen an der grenze fest und
mittendrin in dieser region ist unser
reporter peter wilke peter wir haben
dramatische bilder gesehen ein trunkener
flüchtling flüchtlinge ein polizist mit
schädelbruch wie schlimm ist die lage
momentan was kannst du uns berichten
thomas zumindestens die letzten acht ist
nach dem allen was wir erfahren haben
ruhig geblieben die kommen ja nicht ganz
nah dran an ihren 2 die polnische
regierung der polnische grenzschutz je
nach wie vor so bis der stadt an der
grenze unterbindet und ja sehr erschwert
da nichts zulässt aber da hat es sich
wohl vorerst erst mal beruhigt wir haben
bilder gesehen vom gestrigen abend wo
sich dann eben das zeltlager direkt an
dem grenzzaun wieder aufgebaut hat auf
bella russischer seite mit den
flüchtlingen und den migranten auf der
anderen seite stand zwei bis drei reihen
immer noch grenzpolizisten soldaten und
eben wasserwerfer in alarmbereitschaft
aber das scheint es sich vorerst erst
mal beruhigt zu haben aber da hat es
natürlich gestern ist es zu extrem
auseinandersetzung gekommen schlachten
du hast das gesagt ein polizist wurde
auch auf polnischer seite schwerst am
kopf verletzt musste ins krankenhaus
gebracht werden also da hat es gestern
mittag vor allen dingen dass es zu den
auseinandersetzungen gekommen jetzt aber
wohl hat es sich erstmal beruhigt peter
wir sehen du stehst am grab des toten
flüchtlings was kannst du uns über die
beerdigung erzählen
ja genauso anderer vor am montagabend
ist es hier eben zur beisetzung von
ahmed al hassan gekommen dem 19 jährigen
syrer der schon vor rund einem monat im
grenzfluss tragisch ertrunken ist bzw
von den russischen soldaten wurde er in
diesen grenzenlos hineingetrieben
solltest zumindestens ein freund erzählt
der ihnen auf seiner flucht begleitet
hat und es geschafft hat der hat eben
berichtet das ist die belarussischen
soldaten waren die ihn in den fluss
getrieben haben um ihn über die grenze
zu bekommen aber auch mit konnte eben
nicht schwimmen und ist deswegen
tragisch ertrunken und wurde am
montagabend im hier beerdigt wir können
das grab im hintergrund sehen diese
beisetzung hat in der muslimischen
gemeinde hier in der kleinen
muslimischen gemeinde hier im osten von
polen statt gefunden wurde kostenlos
ermöglicht weil natürlich keine
verwandten die irgendwelche finanziellen
mittel hier vor ort waren wir haben es
auch schon gehört die verwandten wurden
per video zugeschaltet saßen selber in
syrien es gab natürlich halt eben keine
finanziellen mittel um diese beisetzung
zu ermöglichen zum glück war das dann
jetzt aber noch kostenlos möglich es war
auch eine recht kleine feier dieses grab
ist auch hier auf dem friedhof ganz weit
abgelegen von den anderen gräbern der
restlichen gemeinde und wir können es
uns auch noch einmal anschauen eine der
hilfsorganisation die hier tätig ist in
der region die haben dort diese weiße
plastiktüte mit dem kreuz darauf
platziert dass sowohl es uns gesagt ist
meistens das erste ich nenne es mal care
paket das erste erste-hilfe-set was
flüchtlinge bekommen werden sie hier in
polen von den hilfsorganisationen
gerettet werden da sind wärmedecken drin
da sind energydrinks drin da ist alles
mögliche drin was den im ersten moment
erstmal hilft um wieder zu kräften zu
kommen und das hat eben eine der
hilfsorganisation jetzt hier an dem grab
platziert um eben auf das traurige
schicksal von ahmed al hassan aufmerksam
zu machen und eben darauf hinzuweisen
dass die hilfsorganisation nach wie vor
nicht an die grenze dürfen genauso wie
wir journalisten und dass die
hilfsorganisation dort nicht helfen
können und dass sie eben auch sehr
wütend sind weil sie beispielsweise im
fall von ahmed auch leicht ihm noch
hätten retten können ihm helfen können
aber das eben nicht möglich war weil die
polnische regierung hier eben keine
hilfe zulässt
eindrückliche bilder und schilderungen
von peter wilke aus der grenzregion
vielen dank peter und wir schalten
gleich weiter zum außenpolitischen
experten der fdp alexander graf
lambsdorff
wenn sie diese szenen sehen wenn sie
diese schilderungen unseres reporters
hören würden sie nicht die forderung der
hilfsorganisation unterstützen wollen
dass man zumindest diese flüchtlinge die
dort jetzt unter diesen schrecklichen
bedingungen an der grenze ausharren
müssen in die eu aufnehmen sollte
ich glaube dass wir dann in eine
situation geraten dass noch viel mehr
menschen dieses schicksal erleiden
müssten denn die nachrichten würden sich
sofort verbreiten in syrien im irak es
würden sich noch viel mehr junge leute
auf machen familien einzeln stehende
männer die dann versuchen über diese
route nach polen in die europäische
union zu kommen ich glaube so tragisch
das schicksal ist gilt nach wie vor
einsatz und das ist der den ich auch
schon in warschau bei der polnischen
regierung wirklich mit nachdruck
vorgebracht habe die
hilfsorganisation in denen muss erlaubt
werden diesen menschen bei ihren
grundbedürfnissen zu helfen das ist
vollkommen klar dass es eine humanitäre
verpflichtung dennoch bleibt es richtig
dass wir nicht die grenze einfach so auf
machen alle rein lassen das wäre ein
erfolg für lukaschenko das wäre ein
nachgeben der europäischen union
gegenüber der erpressung von einem
diktator aber was ist ihrer meinung nach
jetzt die lösung für dieses dringliche
probleme
weiterhin gespräche mit der polnischen
seite druck und sanktionen auf die
weißrussische seite
um den zugang der hilfsorganisationen zu
ermöglichen ich habe in warschau auch
gesprochen mit der vertreterin des
flüchtlingshochkommissar und die hat
ganz klar gesagt sie haben nur
sporadischen zugang sie hätten
hilfsmittel sie könnten mit decken mit
lebensmitteln mit warmen getränken dort
helfen wenn man sie rein ließe das ist
keine politische maßnahme ist eine
humanitäre maßnahme die sagt überhaupt
nicht etwas darüber aus ob die menschen
und bleiben dürfen oder nicht das
asylverfahren das etwas völlig anderes
aber diese hilfe zu leisten und diese
hilfe zu erlauben das wäre würde ich
erwarten von der polnischen regierung
das würde ich auch erwarten von der
regierung in weißrussland die mitglied
der vereinten nationen ist und deswegen
auch beim hochkommissar für flüchtlinge
der vereinten nationen mitglied und hat
die bundeskanzlerin inzwischen mit dem
weißrussischen machthaber lukaschenko
telefoniert 50 minuten lang wie man hört
offenbar ohne die
anrainerstaaten jedenfalls langfristig
vorab zu informieren
was richtig mit ihm direkt zu sprechen
ich habe mich sehr geärgert darüber dass
ich gelesen habe dass die letten die
litauer die polen nicht über diesen
geplanten anruf informiert waren das ist
diplomatisch nicht geschickt mit in
einem anderen regierungschef sozusagen
über eine situation zu reden diese
länder betrifft ohne sie vorher zu
informieren das war sicher nicht richtig
ob man in einer solch außergewöhnlichen
humanitären krise nicht auch mal zu
ungewöhnlichen diplomatischen schritten
greifen kann das steht auf einem anderen
blatt wenn es gelingt durch ein solches
gespräch eine deeskalation eine
befriedung eine verbesserung der
humanitären lage zu erreichen dann würde
ich jetzt hier den stab nicht brechen
wollen über diesem gespräch über der
bundeskanzlerin aber die diplomatische
einbettung die ist offensichtlich
misslungen denn das war ja auch bei
ihnen in der zeitung nachzulesen die
aufregung in vilnius die aufregung in
riga die aufregung auch in warschau
darüber eben nicht adäquat informiert
worden zu sein die ist groß und die kann
ich auch nachvollziehen das war ja wohl
auch eine deutsch-französische
initiative der französische präsident
marko hatte gleich auch mit den
russischen präsidenten putin gesprochen
und es scheint sich ja jetzt auch etwas
zu bewegen zumindest hat lukaschenko ja
angedeutet dass flüchtlinge zurück
gefährt zurückgeführt werden sollten in
ihre heimatländer für viel glaubhaft
halten sie das ich hoffe dass das
glaubhaft ist man darf lukaschenko
solange nicht glauben bis man nicht
sieht dass das was er sagt auch in die
tat umgesetzt worden ist aber es war
schon bemerkenswert dass gestern morgen
auch der starke mann in polen kaczynski
im polnischen radio gesagt hat er
erwartet jetzt ein ende der anspannungen
dieser angespannten situation
es hat mehrere gespräche gegeben von
frau merkel mit herrn putin makro sie
haben gerade gesagt hat mit putin
besprochen ist hat das telefonat merkel
lukaschenka gegeben also mit anderen
worten die diplomatischen anstrengungen
laufen auf hochtouren gleichzeitig hat
die europäische kommission mit dem irak
gesprochen darüber dass das land seine
staatsbürger zurück nimmt was ja auch
wichtig ist es ist unterbunden worden
dass es weitere flüge nach minsk gibt
aus dem mittleren osten also mit anderen
worten hier läuft auf allen kanälen eine
große diplomatische anstrengungen die
man oft nicht sieht weil sie sich den
kulissen abspielt und das ist bei der
diplomatie manchmal so erfolgreich zu
sein darf es nicht oft der sozusagen
direkt auf dem bildschirm alles
stattfinden oder wie man früher gesagt
hätte an der litfaßsäule sondern es muss
diskret im hintergrund gearbeitet werden
meine hoffnung ist meine hoffnung ist
dass das was sie gefragt haben nämlich
ist das was du geschenke gesagt hat
glaubhaft dass das wirklich auch dann so
ist erste frage graf lambsdorff wenn das
nicht so gelingt welche mittel gibt es
dann noch die eu und sie sind ja europa
politiker hat sich was sanktionen angeht
ja eher als zahnloser tiger bislang
bewiesen welche druckmittel gebe es noch
naja also die sanktionen sind bisher
nicht zahnlos also der die angedrohte
sanktion alleine gegen turkish airlines
reichte ja aus damit die airline jetzt
keine tickets mehr verkauft an syrer
oder irakern die nach minsk fliegen
wollen die irischen gesellschaften die
flugzeuge verchartern an
luftfahrtgesellschaften die solche flüge
durchführen die haben gesagt sie hören
auf damit also es gibt durchaus
sanktionen die auch wirken aber ich
glaube es muss einfach klar sein oder
eine humanitäre versorgung der menschen
ohne druck auf die beiden regierungen
die es hier geht vorbei eines klar ist
weißrussland ist der aggressor polen ist
hier das opfer genau wie litauen oder
lettland wird es nicht gehen wenn diese
lage nicht deeskaliert und deswegen
glaube ich hoffen wir darauf dass die
diplomatischen bemühungen jetzt erfolge
zeitigen ich hab das eben gesagt ich
glaube es gibt auch erste erfolge die
man schon sehen kann und hoffen wir dass
es nicht nötig sein wird hier noch mehr
druck zu machen alexander graf
lambsdorff
vielen dank für das gespräch da gehen